[MUSIC PLAYING]
TRISHA PRABHU: Part of
being in the tech community
means that things
are unpredictable,
and big ideas happen
fast, and you just
have to go, go, go, go, go.
ED COOKE: Creativity
is at its best when
people with different ideas
and different expertises
come together.
SEBASTIAN STRICKER: When we
started with ShareTheMeal,
we had surprisingly
little knowledge
about pretty much everything.
The reason why we stand
where we stand right now
is because we found
people that are
willing to collaborate with us.
RITESH AGARWAL: Collaboration
was not necessary,
it essential.
All your partners are the most
important part of the puzzle.
We have been able
to work together
with those hotel
partners, and they have
responded in a massive way.
GONZALO RODRIGUEZ:
Since I was a child,
I always wanted to
create something
that creates an impact
on thousands of people.
I found that, with
technology and collaboration,
we could do it.
TRISHA PRABHU: We are
this new internet age.
And what's so exciting
is we get to be
the first to make a difference.
And we get to
harness that power.
Behind every
successful person is
a group of people
making it happen,
helping to organize, and put
things together, and think
about things.
ED COOKE: At Memrise, we've got
coders, film makers, linguists,
product designers, and a
crazy Italian bus driver.
We've got a whole
community of people
around Europe participating
in the creation
of this video dictionary of
all of Europe's languages.
[NON-ENGLISH]
SEBASTIAN STRICKER: We
found out that there
are 20 times as many people
that have smartphones
than hungry children.
And ShareTheMeal wanted
to make it as easy
as possible for people to
do good, whenever they want,
wherever they are.
RITESH AGARWAL:
India, on one side had
three million rooms available.
On the other side, there
was half a billion people
who wanted to stay.
I realized that there
was a huge amount
of problem in being able to
connect both of these people.
Our aspiration was
saying, we will
solve it, which is why, for
three months, almost every day,
I would stay in a new motel,
a guest house, a service
department.
GONZALO RODRIGUEZ: And
with the use of technology,
we can create great
games that will
help kids be smarter every day.
Today, we feel that
there are no barriers.
We can have anyone from all
over the world working with us.
And that is a nice thing.
TRISHA PRABHU: I
am the generation
that was the first to
grow up with technology.
And so I wanted
to use technology
to solve a problem that I think
technology itself has created.
ReThink is able to detect when
the combination of keystrokes
creates offensive
content or hurtful words.
We provide a second chance
to reconsider their decision.
ED COOKE: Technology
allows people anywhere
to come into contact
with anything.
It makes connections.
It extends people's powers.
It makes things which weren't
accessible, accessible.
RITESH AGARWAL: Feels great
that we have the smartest
brains in the country
coming together and solving
a problem more passionately
than the founder who actually
started it.
And we'll do anything
to make it successful.
There's one thing about Play
Store that I can tell you.
They make sure that you
learn almost every week
or every month, because
they're themselves
making their systems better.
And we're all learning together.
SEBASTIAN STRICKER:
We didn't know
whether this would turn out
to be an innovation that
is impactful.
And as of today, we stand
roughly 7.3 million daily food
rations, so far.
TRISHA PRABHU: Coding
opens doors to make it
more than just an app.
People everywhere
are standing up,
uniting behind a
piece of technology
that they think has the
potential to change the world.
That's amazing.
RITESH AGARWAL: The
next five or ten years
are possibly the
most exciting times,
which means, if we
can bring all of them
together, collaborate, and bring
something to users which really
solves a problem, I'm pretty
sure that a lot of these things
will form the basis to building
better nations in times
to come.
[MUSIC PLAYING]